moscou il y a quelques semaines cela
fait un an que anna politkovskaïa est
morte j'ai l'impression étrange que son
pays il a peut-être oublié
dans les rues partout des affiches à la
gloire de vladimir poutine comme celle
ci le plan de poutine c'est la victoire
de la russie je me demande ce qu'anna
aurait pensé de ces affiches
anna journalistes russes témoins de la
tragédie de son pays et de la brutalité
de la guerre en tchétchénie hanin dont
je me souviens sans cesse des mots
quelques semaines avant sa mort ou
picturales c'est terrifiant aujourd'hui
en russie tu es quelqu'un n'est rien
prague est ce que c'est devenu sans
importance
au fait que cela me fait peur dans mon
pays on tue web store et puis on oublie
ce jour là ils ne sont que quelques
centaines venus pour elle place
pouchkine 300 à se souvenir
en sa mémoire des amis des proches les
collègues mais surtout tous ceux pour
qui l écrivait ces hommes et ces femmes
qu'elles avaient pu aider un jour des
fleurs des bougies un moment de
recueillement vite interrompue par des
policiers qui s'en prennent à un dessin
d'enfant comme si le pouvoir avait
encore peur de celle qui était la voix
de la russie et de ses souffrances tous
ici ont en mémoire les mots de vladimir
poutine trois jours après sa mort d'un
disc
8-7 aux journalistes que cette
journaliste était effectivement très
critique du pouvoir actuel en russie
il ya donc mais les experts le savent
aussi très bien l'affluence de son
travail sur la vie politique russe et
délits est totalement insignifiant
[Musique]
la dernière fois que j'avais vu alain
c'était à la rédaction son journal deux
mois avant sa mort elle m'aidait à faire
un reportage sur les soldats qui
rentrait de tchétchénie et que l'état
russe le cdh à la dérive
nous avions parlé de la souffrance de
ces jeunes appelés mais aussi comme à
chacune de nos rencontres de son pays de
son métier et de tous ces russes qui lui
écrivait lui demander de l'aide
le problème principal de ce pays a trop
d'eau c'est l'attitude de l'état face à
l'individu le citoyen
je pense que notre pouvoir ne s'est pas
débarrassé du syndrome stalinien selon
lequel l'homme n'est rien
à part ou je te tue pas que de la
poussière sous les bottes de l'état
la vie humaine ne vaut rien
et on devrait se résigner à cela
qu du garric je suis absolument contre
une telle attitude de l'état
et c'est pour cela que je lutte de
toutes mes forces tout que ce que
j'écris sur les gens sur les problèmes
de ce pays c'est mon but écrire plus ne
pas arrêter d'écrire et dès que je le
peux parler
aujourd'hui je retrouve novaïa gazeta
sant anna des couloirs ville et puis
dans son bureau je revois ces deux amis
de toujours zoya également partager ses
rencontres pendant plus de sept ans
le couloir était rempli de gens qui
venaient la voir ils venaient d'un peu
partout en russie
d'autres étaient assis ici près de son
bureau
voilà là c'est son bureau et les gens
sont assez ici là bas c'était incroyable
je défendrai toujours les faibles ceux
qui n'avaient pas de droits qui ne
savaient pas où aller
un art santé tout leur douleur au plus
profond d'elle-même sinon elle n'aurait
pas écrit ces articles elle n'aurait pas
fait ses reportages
soldats russes qui filait une arme est
devenu criminel
mères de soldats ayant perdu trace de
leur fils au combat ou dans un régiment
famille tchétchène cherchant un proche
disparu dans une guerre sans fin
[Musique]
il a juste eu tenu qu on ne peut pas se
protéger de toute cette souffrance
moi je me dis juste que je suis devenu
le témoin de ces événements sur
benetton et je ne veux pas avoir honte
devant les petits enfants le jour où ils
me demanderont mais tu étais là toi
pourquoi tu laissé faire moi je veux
pouvoir répondre j'ai lutté
au détour d'un couloir je retrouve
dimitri muratov le rédacteur en chef dan
dah après sa mort dimitri a voulu tout
arrêter mais ces journalistes n'ont
dissuadé en mémoire de tous ceux qui ne
sont plus là trois journalistes ont été
assassinés en quatre ans à novaïa gazeta
ne s'arrêtait pas la seule fonction
journalistique d'informer se mêler de la
vie totalement elle était dedans elle
était le contraire des journalistes de
salon schatz tokyo avec anna tout
commençait une fois l'article ceux
publiés
si pour la plupart to termine quand
l'article dans le journal
pour un as et est le commencement le
début de la lutte pour la justice
la lutte pour la justice dames 1
anna journalistes mais aussi militante
ou négociatrice comme sur ces images
lors de la prise d'otages du théâtre de
la doubrovka à moscou
ne perdons pas de temps si on a des jus
de fruits il faut y aller maintenant
anna sauvera des dizaines de vies en
apportant des vivres elle tentera
d'instaurer le dialogue avec le commando
tchétchène en vain elle ne pourra
empêcher l'assaut sanglant des troupes
russes
deux ans plus tard autre carnage
la prise d'otages dans une école de
beslan ana sera empêché de s'y rendre
empoisonné dans un avion alors qu'elle
était en route l'état voulait empêcher
toute possibilité de négociation
depuis le poison était dans son corps
mais anna s'est battu jusqu'à la fin
pour qu'on n'oublie pas les enfants de
beslan
je me sens coupable
coupable de ne pas avoir pu arrêter
cette guerre
coupable qu'on ait laissé tout seul à
arriver
[Musique]
l'engagement danas est ici dans une
vieille ruelles de moscou que je vais en
trouver l'origine
j'ai rendez vous avec son mari alexander
aujourd'hui il réalise des documentaires
sur la culture russe ancien journaliste
d'investigation il a dû renoncer à 6 ans
4 face aux pressions du pouvoir il se
souvient du jour où anna s'est lancé
dans sa lutte pour la justice
jallet un reportage à travers le pays
j'allais dans les prisons
et puis elle m'a accompagné
des défenseurs des droits de l'homme où
tu lui ont donné des contacts des
numéros de téléphone
et puis cela s'est enchaîné logiquement
comme une évidence
les entrées de plain pied dans sa lutte
où l'homme et son destin était la valeur
essentielle
[Musique]
alexander politkovski était un
journaliste vedette des années 90 c'est
lui qui a créé la première émission
d'investigation de la télévision us
il tient à me montrer ses archives
personnelles ces reportages lorsqu'il
couvrait les derniers soubresauts de
l'urss
[Musique]
avec ces documents il veut me faire
comprendre l'engagement de sa femme sur
ces images exceptionnelles je découvre
un autre visage danois elle a 25 ans
c'est une jeune maman qui attend
alexander à la maison avec liliane astia
les enfants anin qui déjà se confronte
aux dangers du métier et aux menaces de
mort que reçoit son mari
[Applaudissements]
le ministre gignac
unia tartam en jetons retenue j'ai
appris beaucoup rejeté yahoo je saute
émotions jouent
le pire qu'on aurait pu faire à anas
était de s'attaquer à ses enfants
c'était une maman inquiète quand ils
sortent elles avaient peur au vote mais
en même temps on se disait on ne peut
pas vivre toujours dans la peur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous
c'est la naissance d'une vocation au fil
des reportages d'alexander 1-1 s'engage
peu à peu à sa suite dans cette volonté
de témoigner des bouleversements de leur
pays
charles a connu une trace cousineau du
mois
petit qui rouge
on était plus pas bien belichick tati
monnaie
d'autres soulignent haute
malheureusement avec anna cela s'est
terminé de manière tragique
l'ennemi en face était trop grand
il était trop pervers
et si cela continue comme ça ce ne sera
pas le dernier événement tragique en
russie le dernier meurtre
qui a tué cette question me hante j'ai
en tête ces dernières images d'une
caméra surveillance sur son palier ces
dernières images de vie et puis cette
silhouette celle du tueur qui vient de
la battre de quatre balles dans le corps
ces images aussi lors de son enterrement
des milliers de personnes venues se
recueillir près de la tombe de celle qui
symbolisait une autre idée de la russie
un an après sa mort plusieurs pistes ont
été suivies celle d'officier mis en
cause par anna et qui se serait vengé
celle de groupes néo nazis pour qui anna
était la femme à abattre accusé de
collaboration avec l'occident et puis
surtout la piste qui remonteraient
jusqu'au président tchétchène ramzan
kadirov le protégé de vladimir poutine
hamelin dénoncée régulièrement ses
méthodes brutales et avait rassemblé des
preuves qu'il impliqué dans plusieurs
cas de tortures et de meurtres
le jour de l'anniversaire de kadirov ana
avait donné cette interview
[Musique]
ce sont les derniers mots dames 1 quatre
jours plus tard elle était assassinée
depuis son fils ilia se bat aux côtés de
dimitri muratov le rédacteur en chef de
novaïa gazeta pour connaître la vérité
elle vous parler des menaces qui peut
essuyer oui on en parlait
mais maman était le genre de personne je
compte pouvait convaincre de s'arrêter à
cause du danger
il considérait que c'était son devoir
on ne pouvait absolument rien faire
elle disait quoi
elle disait je dois le faire les gens
viennent me voir je dois les aider
vous croyez qu'un jour vous saurez qui a
tué votre mère
pour moi je trouve et je l'espère oui
mais en russie les meurtres de
journalistes ont rarement été élucidés
l'ancien rédacteur en chef de novaïa
gazeta est empoisonnée et l' affaire a
été classée vous n'avez pas peur que
cela se reproduise
à quoi bon oui j'ai peur de cela mais
j'ai surtout peur des pressions du
pouvoir sur les gens en charge de
l'enquêté mois pour l'instant ça va et
je ne sais pas combien de temps cela va
durer
les craintes dia se confirme le
lendemain nous apprenons que l' enquête
se rapproche du sommet du pouvoir plus
précisément du fsb l'ancien kgb les
services secrets aux commandes en russie
je décide de me rendre à echo de moscou
la seule radio encore indépendante en
russie le seul média qui suit sans
relâche des développements de l'enquète
dimitri muratov le rédacteur en chef de
novaïa gazeta est l'invité du jour ici
ces dernières révélations inquiète si
des membres du fsb ont participé au
meurtre il est peu probable que l'on
connaisse un jour le commanditaire
nous avons très peur que des membres du
fsb les services de sécurité russes
essaient de faire échouer l enquête car
ils sont eux mêmes impliqués ce comme
prise assure nous en avons la preuve des
membres des services de sécurité russes
ont aidé à organiser l'assassinât d'anna
d'anciens officiers mais aussi des
officiers hauts placés toujours en
exercice ils ont loué leurs services à
des milieux criminels
ce sont eux qui ont aidé à organiser les
filatures de hannah la mise sur écoute
de ses téléphones tout cela a été
orchestré par des membres des services
de sécurité du pays
c'est extrêmement grave
la parole libre de ceux qui résistent
encore en russie dimitri mouratov les
journalistes de novaïa gazeta qui
enquêtent sur le meurtre d'anne mais
aussi les jeunes reporters d'écho de
moscou tous sont régulièrement menacés
de man show mis de côté ce qui est
terrible c'est l'indifférence de la
société russe on a tué anna et voilà les
gens sont passés à autre chose moi je
lutte de toutes mes forces pour qu'on ne
s'habitue pas aux moeurs
l'oubli l'habitude au meurtre si
fréquent des journalistes russes
l'indifférence d'une société occupés à
survivre
les trottoirs de moscou la foule je
cherche un souvenir d'allemands une
trace
pourquoi vous pensez qu'on a tué anna
politkovskaïa ouais je sais pas quoi
vous dire et vous j'ai pas entendu
pourquoi vous pensez qu'on a tué anna
politkovskaïa je sais pas et pour vous
c'était qui je ne sais même pas qui
c'est
pourquoi on a tué anna politkovskaïa qui
ça anna politkovskaïa la journaliste
excusez moi je ne sais pas qui c'est
pourquoi on a tué anna parce qu'elle
disait la vérité seulement pour cela
mais chez nous en russie on n'aime pas
la vérité
dans ce kiosque de la place pouchkine
natacha tente de maintenir en vie la
mémoire d'anne elle persiste à vouloir
vendre novaïa gazeta seul journal encore
indépendants en russie les autres
kiosques alentours ont renoncé google
vous savez mon kiosque il est sous
surveillance parce que l'on vend des
journaux d'opposition et des livres de
journalistes indépendants comme celui
d'anna de plus en plus souvent des
hommes en costume viennent me dire c'est
quoi ses livres ses journaux il voit
cela il dit c'est quoi cette propagande
nouvelle église état c'est de la
propagande il faut croire
que j'ai dit si
plus vite que ça sinon on va les régler
ça ailleurs allez dégagez si je vous dis
je n'ai pas si éloigné vous c'est un
passant qui agresse une caméra parce
qu'elle file le journal de m natacha
s'est habituée ces derniers temps aux
menaces
vous avez compris maintenant ce que
c'est à cet endroit
c'est devenu dangereux dans un journal
comme vous le voyez je dis toujours à
mes employeurs que je devrais avoir une
prime de risque c'est terrible
je me dis qu'en quelques mois à peine ce
pays a bien changé aujourd'hui être
résistant c'est vendre un journal encore
indépendant je repars sur les traces de
la mémoire d'anne je retrouve andreï
mironov un ami commun souvent croisé en
tchétchénie andrei et des derniers
compagnons de route dana
ancien dissident dray a fait plusieurs
années de goulag aujourd'hui le travail
pour memorial une association qui
répertorie tous les crimes commis en
tchétchénie
la dernière fois que l'on s'est vu une
vingtaine de jours avant sa mort elle
m'a dit qu'elle se préparait à mourir
m'a dit qu'il était même étonné d'être
encore en vie
ce n'était pas une confidence mais
plutôt la conversation d'un soldat qui
va à la guerre et qui voit les morts
autour de lui et se prépare à son tour à
mourir
c'était comme à la guerre
et on estime à 10 et étrangers ces
derniers temps les menaces se sont
arrêtées
sept aujourd'hui je comprends c'est
parce qu'ils avaient décidé de passer à
l'acte
nous aussi on dit que tant que tu est
menacé c'est que ton tour n'est pas
encore venu
ce pouvoir est totalitaire ou
totalitaires depuis la racine
quelqu'un comme poutine ne peut tolérer
la moindre brèche dans l'ordre qu'il a
été
ta ble devant lui doit être lisse sans
une fissure
et il ne peut supporter la moindre
quantité tâche et anna politovskaïa l
aile gâcher le tableau est pour lui
c'était insupportable
elle gênait la propagande comme une
fausse note dans la musique de poutine
numéro dieu
andrei m'emmène à nijni novgorod à 400
km de moscou
des nouvelles inquiétantes lui sont
parvenus il
y a quelques jours il ya eu une descente
de la police dans les locaux de
l'édition régionale de novaïa gazeta
tous les ordinateurs ont été confisqués
le journal ne peut plus paraître
depuis la mort d'anna le pouvoir a
renforcé son contrôle sur les médias
locaux
andrei retrouve les journalistes de
novaïa gazeta des amis de longue date
anna
vous voyez ils ont tout emmener
les disques durs ont été confisqués il
reste plus que les fils et les écrans
cynisme des autorités
la descente de police a eu lieu alors
que le journal s'apprêtait à organiser
une conférence pour la date anniversaire
de la mort d'anne pourquoi ils ont fait
cette descente ici et maintenant
ce qu'on est le seul journal de la
région qui n'est pas censuré avec des
journalistes indépendants
mais pourquoi vous êtes une menace pour
le pays
oui ils ont peur pour eux on est une
menace
je ne comprends pas pourquoi j'aimerais
bien savoir en quoi on est si menaçant
avec notre poignée de journalistes
en fait le pouvoir ne supporte pas le
moindre mouvement de contestation ou de
voies différentes ils ont peur que les
gens commencent à réfléchir à s'unir des
gens qui ne pensent pas comme tous ceux
au kremlin
quelques jours après notre tournage
oksana estas se feront arrêter pour
avoir voulu organiser la conférence en
mémoire d'anne en
plus grave encore alors que je quitte
nijni novgorod
j'entends parler du retour d'une sombre
pratique du temps de la russie
soviétique
l'enfermement psychiatrique pour les
gêneurs
je parviens à me procurer ces images
elles ont été filmées le jour de la
libération de larissa re
larissa que l'on voit sortir de la
voiture a été interné pendant près de
deux mois dans un hôpital psychiatrique
à mourmansk au nord de la russie son
crime elle avait dénoncé dans un journal
local
les conditions de traitement des
patients dans ces mêmes hôpitaux
vous voyez les revenus votre fille elle
est en vie c'est l'essentiel
c'était tellement dur et tellement dur
piqûre calment électrochoc fin d'un
cauchemar qui a duré deux mois sous la
pression internationale
les autorités ont fini par relâcher
larissa
ils m'ont enfermé pour se venger de
l'article que j'avais écrit sur les
hôpitaux psychiatriques une fausse
facture et parce que j'en ai parlé à la
tribune pendant un meeting de
l'opposition
dans cet article je dénonçais les
enfermements abusif et dans les hôpitaux
psychiatriques
et le retour de l'utilisation de la
psychiatrie à des fins politiques et
voilà ce qu'ils m'ont fait union dans le
cadre du monde arrêtez m'ont pris mes
papiers et mendient
tu es malade on va te soigner à notre
manière
ils m'ont forcé avalé des médicaments
assure qu'ils m'ont donnée m'a rendu
malade j'ai eu des vomissements comme il
n'ya pas ton des malaises
même les fascistes ne se comportait pas
comme ça pendant la guerre
je suis allé la voir à l'hôpital elle
m'a dit maman regarde ce qu'ils m'ont
fait ses jambes étaient couvertes de
bleus de cicatrices
merci à les rentrer d'une bombe je monte
un pauvre je remercie tous ceux qui nous
ont aidés à la faire sortir
je suis tellement heureuse enfin elle
est à la maison
cela faisait des mois que je ne dormais
plus
[Musique]
larissa n'est pas la seule j'entends
parler d'un autre cas d'enfermement d'un
journaliste dans un hôpital
psychiatrique
segal yal ami d'anna qui m'a alerté nous
partons pour rybinski à 350 km de moscou
sept heures de route pour retrouver la
trace d'andrea novicov journaliste
indépendant enfermé depuis 10 mois
devant un cas d'internement
psychiatrique forcer une personne en
bonne santé je suis certaine qu'elle
instaurait tout de suite venu dans cette
ville de rufisque pour enquêter et
mettre fin à cet enfer
c'est une lettre du père d'andré novikov
qui a alerté gallia dans les années 90
andré était un célèbre éditorialiste à
moscou épuisé les revenus dans sa ville
natale où il a continué à écrire des
articles critiques contre le kremlin et
les autorités locales il dénonçait aussi
les exactions des soldats russes de
rybinski en tchétchénie
nous suivons gallia dans l'hôpital
psychiatrique où est interné en draine
images volées d'une époque que l'on
croyait révolue
c'est le jour de visite des familles
nous parvenons à entrer
ce sont les premières images d'andrea
novicov
prisonnier politique de la russie de
vladimir poutine ignoré de tous
comment vous vous sentez
cela fait tellement longtemps que je
suis là depuis le 14 février 2007
c'est terrible cet enfermement
c'est insupportable
racontez moi
on est 15 par chambre ouais je suis avec
des détenus des criminels et vous
humilie
cela va un peu mieux maintenant mais au
début pendant des mois ils m'ont menacé
m'ont tabassé
j'en peux plus et vous ont fait du mal
oui bien sûr ils m'ont frappé
et les médecins m'ont dit que si je
voulais un jour sortir d'ici il fallait
que j'arrête d'écrire ils me l'ont fait
comprendre très clairement
je crois qu'en russie aujourd'hui les
gens comme moi les journalistes libres
soit on les tue soit on les met en
prison soit on les enferme dans des
hôpitaux psychiatriques
des gens que moi devraient être défendus
par la communauté internationale comme
les dissidents à l'époque soviétique
sinon le pouvoir peut continuer à faire
ce qu'il veut de nous enfermer nous
briser nous faire disparaître
interne et un journaliste pour ses idées
en russie en 2007 violent retour du
passé l'internement politique avait été
interdite par gorbatchev pendant la
pérestroïka
nous retrouvons l'adresse des parents
d'andré qui vivent à quelques kilomètres
de l'hôpital des parents désemparés qui
depuis dix mois tente de faire sortir
leur fils de son enfer
le père un ancien militaire découvre la
réalité du système il tient à nous
montrer les expertises psychiatriques
qu'il a reçus justifiant l'internement
force et de son fils
neo pour lui didier massias chiot attise
l'attitude du patient montre qu'il a un
comportement antisocial aussi épineux la
commission vient à la conclusion que
l'état de troubles psychologiques andreï
novikov fait qu'il n'est pas en mesure
de se rendre compte du danger que
représente son comportement ses idées
son regard sur le monde
la commission conclut qu andreï novikov
est un danger pour la société et doit
être interné
juste avant son internement voilà en
bref dans son dossier médical on leur
reproche aussi ses sympathies pour
l'opposition ultime accusations
justifiant la prison chimiques
c'est son deuxième séjour en psychiatrie
fort c'est
la première fois qu'ils l'ont enfermé
c'était horrible ils lui ont brûlé sa
barbe il ne le laissait pas dormir ils
ont même essayé de le violer et quand il
est revenu à la maison il l'avait
tellement drogué de médicaments qu'il
était méconnaissable
il marchait comme un zombie un vrai
rouleau il arrivait à peine à parler ils
me disaient ils m'ont donné tellement de
médicaments que cela me sortait par les
oreilles votre campagne et voilà ce qui
lui ont fait subir dans cet endroit sur
quoi vous pensez que le pouvoir vous
confirmer votre fils pour être
tranquille avant les élections pour que
tout reste en ordre
andré il m'a raconté que régulièrement
des hommes fsd viennent dans l'hôpital
et lui ont dit qu'il était un
sympathisant des terroristes tchétchènes
landry leur a répondu je suis
journaliste la seule chose que j'ai fait
c'est écrire je n'ai rien fait trop
les hommes du fsd font pression sur les
médecins qu'ils ne le relâche pas
oui ils ont rassemblé des documents des
tas de documents contre lui et je crois
que leur but c'est de le garder enfermé
à vie
je veux porter un toast à landry limouzy
shaun hill est en train de vivre quelque
chose de très dur
j'espère qu'il va surmonter cette
épreuve vous dire j'étais tspo cannes
c'est très dur aussi pour nous ses
parents de le voir dans cet état
on aimerait qu'il revienne à la maison
et le plus vite possible coach compostri
de lancer de moins
solitude de parents confrontés à la
violence du système
solitude de hanna qui sillonnaient sans
fin son pays pour raconter ses histoires
d'hommes et de femmes qui tentent de
résister cette russie que l'on entend de
moins en moins depuis qu'elle n'est plus
là
[Musique]